[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants ne fait pas de bruit
nounours a mal à la tête pauvre nounours
colle mal d'auteurs patron je descends
juste embrassé mes deux petits amis et
je remonte à tous ces hits north
molsheim où l'europe ou le dos aux fonds
propres
[Musique]
bonsoir mes pauvres petits chéris
émeutes au fait qu'est ce que tu as j'ai
mal j'ai tellement moment à l'autre mon
petit nous
nous assieds toi vote soigner oui au
mont non non non on a bien là cette
attaque
madame est lui assez sert abonnés pour
sa tête n'est pas bonne pour cet atelier
l'himalaya bas de son dos
mon âme de mon âme bien monsieur et
madame lui a fait faire une peur de le
noble et percu lunettes bleu bonnet pour
s'attaquer à la bo de soul de l'eau non
non non non non non a bien mollasson
mais à terme il n'y a fait faire de la
pommade coffret de la pommade coffrets
et cartes des lunettes plus de fans pour
sa tête et delilah l'aveu de son dos
mon âne de montmagny à bien par la saq
hors jeu prenant comme yavé faire là bas
tant de ses produits impactant que scott
d'orge coup de la pommade couvrir les
pertes des lunettes bleues boucou pas né
pour sa thèse
[Musique]
dieu me le son ventre la dame lui a fait
faire de la dizaine de matelas dizaines
de montres bagues sucre d'orge
cela peut maintenant frais alors comment
te sens tu à présent mon nom est encore
mal à la tête je suis guéri les enfants
se sucre d'or est un rebelle merveilleux
pour les mots d'auteur merci les petits
voilà j'arrive pas trop je me sauve mais
petit à 21h les soigne toi bien ne vous
inquiétez pas je mangerai tout le sucre
d'orge me
[Rires]
où
[Musique]
l'ennuyer enfants mais voilà notre
nounours qui remonte on a une allure
north peut-être au clan mais je n'ai
plus balle à la tête
je suis guéri patron les dessous de 1000
$ et des fruits du poro allant en route
gros gourmand
bonne nuit faute de pont rue
où